hey guys I'm Brian right and I'm Taylor
Bradley so people have been asking me to
check out a documentary trailer don't
really check these out too often it's
called the nightmare
okay I'm excited I got like scared all
the sudden did you really like a
documentary called the nightmare like
that sounds more I did anyway
laying down to go to sleep I would feel
utterly exhausted almost as if I had
just been dropped and my eyes sealed
shut my mouth sealed shut and it's as if
everything was shutting down except for
my awareness my consciousness
Oh
I have zero control over my body no
matter how hard I try to complete with
my arms my writings and we're trying to
fight it it was just so strong and then
you wake hoping you totally paralyzed me
I began hearing voices and screams and
crying I would hear all the sounds but
[Music]
and that is where the shadow man would
come in you could walk disjointed
[Music]
it's a kind of horror that is worse than
like a toy
[Music]
wait a minute
it was sleep paralysis okay I notice Lee
processes but are they saying suggesting
that they all see like demon shadow
things like when they sleep like all
these people or is it just like this one
person I think it's a couple people and
it's it's a common thing okay
I'm the perfect person to watch this
with because I have had sleep paralysis
happen to me that sounds like a joyful
experience and it was the worst thing
I've ever experienced in my whole life
and it's basically that and I did see a
shadow person and it's a very common
thing and it comes from like there's
this old idea that sleep paralysis is
like this old woman who basically sits
on your chest and takes your breath away
until you potentially die and that's
what you hear like hell and you hear all
of these scary horrible things and
shadow people are a very very common
thing to see and sleep paralysis like
cause shadow people and demons are like
the thing that happens and so yeah I
just freak it out over here because yes
that is completely true I've experienced
sleep paralysis and never like seen or
heard anything like that though like
ever it's it's ridiculously scary it's
it's a very common thing people will
like hear things about like death and
hell and they'll feel like they're dying
and you'll see people and they'll see
creatures and things I've experienced
brought like probably several minor
experiences of it whenever I have it is
terrifying like when you're like awake
but you just can't move it like you're
paralyzed yes it's terrifying yes can I
open your mouth you just have to like
focus so hard on trying to have one
small part of your body and once you can
do that then you can come out of it the
worst sleep paralysis I had was when I
was went out for like a couple weeks
where I just couldn't open my eyes like
I've you awake but my my eyes just
refused to like open a little for weeks
no I didn't it closed for weeks I'm
saying like okay I leap and then I would
experience sleeper Alex right like every
single day for weeks yeah that was
pretty bad that is scary when you feel
like your eyelids have
and sewn together shine yeah it's really
like you start freaking out like what I
never open again no no and you're like
what if I'm dead and what if this is
just forever no I know mine I had to
open my eyes but I couldn't move and
that was really really frightening
because I could see things around me and
I could like feel people in the room
with me it was horrible I'm not seeing
this movie this was a horrible I'm
interested to see it no it's a
documentary makes it really intriguing
because there's so many like mock
documentary horror famous clown
mockumentary mockumentaries found
footage films it's interesting to be
like we got a legit documentary about
sleep paralysis and out or refining it I
know that sounds interesting I know I'm
really not there were no jump scares
that's what I mean like it looks
genuinely like psychologically scary
rating time I will definitely be awake
in the theaters to see the nightmare
the nightmare the nightmare I really
want to see it but I'm worried about my
psychological well-being so I feel like
I'll probably see it if it comes out
again Netflix I'm all about Netflix so I
think if it comes out on Netflix and
I'll be able to shut it off or walk away
from it without having to spend twenty
dollars then I will probably watch it
when it comes to Netflix at least a part
of it yeah that's too much for me to put
in a title text and freeze-frame so
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out Taylor's most recently
relaunched channel pretty awesome stuff
and it's like more than like vlogging
there's actual like material we got that
domitor that's pretty awesome and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where we're trying to get a
product placement for I really should
like by a set of props or something one
day what about this mess I love the
mouse that come with you know that you
buy for your computers it allows you to
navigate through the computer makes it
easier than using some pad on your
laptop and it gets you access faster
that's you know going
one sights like when you go on like porn
of like there's so many videos if you
want to just like oh yeah done I got
like 10 seconds and then moot you move
on and get that ten seconds and then you
open up multiple once as you're like
which one do I want to come to this
makes it easier to do the process Goblin
Inman hey Ryan and the rest of ya of
watching you guys for loomed while and
it would be the [ __ ] if ya gave me a
shout out I got a joke to read this how
do shinies people name their babies they
throw them down the stairs to see what
sound they make
that's hilarious anyway my name is Isaac
and men can i have a shout out I like
you better as goblin yeah Goblin Inman
is the actual name do you learn how to
spell better somethings grammatically
wrong unless your vocabulary unless he's
doing it to be cool maybe or he might be
from another country doesn't speak
English that well that's true regardless
if an American were to come across this
they would their exact words would be
this goblin in Maine guy is one of the
biggest [ __ ] idiots I've ever heard
about so you might want to work on your
spelling